From improvised comedy gold
to genuine babbling blunders,
these bloopers had us sticking around — and
laughing hysterically — during the credits.
Following his star-making debut on
"Saturday Night Live" in the 1980s,
Eddie Murphy went on to have a fruitful
career in comedies, with notable hits
like "Beverly Hills Cop" and "Trading Places."
In 1996, he continued that golden streak with
"The Nutty Professor," a remake of the 1963
classic starring Jerry Lewis. Murphy plays
Sherman Klump, a morbidly obese man who, in
a Jekyll-and-Hyde-esque science experiment,
transforms himself into the overconfident Buddy
Love in order to win over the woman of his dreams.
As he does in a number of his films, Murphy takes
on several roles throughout the film, including
other members of the Klump family. This results in
a couple of wild family dinner sequences that are
as funny as they are chaotic. However, the true
hilarity of this scene is best shown in the end
credits outtakes, which depict Murphy breaking
character as he tries to perform each part.
Scored to the song "Macho Man" by the Village
People, the bloopers feature a number of fart
jokes that make Eddie and the rest of the cast
and crew break down into fits of laughter.
When you manage to get Jim Carrey to
be the face of your studio comedy,
it's usually best to just let him go wild
on camera. The comedian is known for his
over-the-top improvisations in films like "Dumb
and Dumber" and "The Truman Show," a talent
that's on full display during the end-credits
blooper reel of "Liar Liar." Released in 1997,
"Liar Liar" stars Carrey as an ethically
challenged lawyer whose son wishes for him
to be forced to tell the truth for one day. It
provides lots of great opportunities for Carrey
to shine with physical comedy, including an iconic
scene in which he beats himself up in a bathroom.
The bloopers at the end of "Liar
Liar" reveal just how much fun it
was for everyone else on set to be a
witness to Carrey's brilliance — his
improvisations never fail to get the crew to
burst out into hysterical laughter. He’s an
outstanding comedic presence on screen,
as well as a charismatic leading man.
"No! Wait! I—(breaks down into gibberish)"
Hollywood was positive about Carrey's
work in the film too, and he scored a
Golden Globe nomination for best performance
by an actor in a motion picture — comedy.
In a true display of his range, Carrey also
ended up with a Globe the following year for
best performance by an actor in a motion
picture — drama for "The Truman Show."
In 2022, Tim Allen reprised his role as
Scott Calvin, a family man who inherits
the role of Santa Claus, in the Disney+
series "The Santa Clauses." However,
the story first began in 1994 with "The
Santa Clause," and was then followed up
with two sequels: one in 2002 and another in
2006. The final installment of the trilogy,
"The Santa Clause 3: The Escape Clause,"
finds Scott desperate to reclaim his
position as Santa after mischief caused
by Jack Frost causes him to lose his job.
Frost is played by comedy legend Martin Short in
the film, and during the end-credits
bloopers, audiences can see the magic
that resulted from having two comedic
icons on the screen at the same time.
"Allen and Smartboth scream in a goofy, over dramatic way,
stop, then resume screaming. Allen laughs."
Although "The Santa Clause 3" was a
critical failure, it performed decently
at the box office. Regardless, it remains a
beloved series set around a joyous holiday,
with the end-credits bloopers showcasing
a similar kind of fun that was had on set.
"Is my acting somehow humorous to you?"
Although many moviegoers know Zach Galifianakis
for his appearances in films like "The Hangover"
and "Due Date," those who follow him online
are familiar with a different side of the
comedian. His comedy talk show, "Between
Two Ferns," debuted on Funny or Die in 2008,
featuring high profile guests ranging
from Brad Pitt to Barack Obama.
When it was announced that "Between Two Ferns"
would make the jump to feature-length comedy,
many fans of the series were puzzled as to how
it would work as a longer story. Nonetheless,
"Between Two Ferns: The Movie" premiered on
Netflix in 2019 and saw Galifianakis play a
fictional version of himself as he interviews
celebrities and tries to keep his show alive.
Featuring cameos from celebrities like Brie
Larson, Keanu Reeves, and Benedict Cumberbatch,
the film was subject to decent reviews
and compared to some of the more watchable
"Saturday Night Live" spinoffs. Of course, one
of the best parts comes during the end credits,
when we see some of the takes that
didn't make it into the final cut.
Given that "Between Two Ferns" bloopers
are hard to come by — to the point that
it's not always clear whether Galifanakis
is being serious or making a joke — it
makes for a heartwarming ending to see
Galifianakis break character in between
insults. It seems like everyone involved
had a blast making the movie — especially
Paul Rudd, whose improvisations turn
Galifianakis red-faced and hysterical.
"Oh… James Franco wears corrective lenses."
Will Ferrell's movies were some
of the best studio comedies throughout the early
2000s. Hot off of "Saturday Night Live," Ferrell
starred in critically-acclaimed comedies
like "Elf," "Zoolander," and "Anchorman:
The Legend of Ron Burgundy." His films also often
contain end-credits blooper reels — like the first
"Anchorman" movie, which features Ferrell making
his castmates break during improvised scenes.
Following the success of his earlier films,
Ferrell teamed up with actor John C. Reilly
in 2006's "Talladega Nights: The Ballad
of Ricky Bobby," a spiritual successor to
"Anchorman" centered on the world of race car
driving. Ferrell plays the titular Ricky Bobby,
a NASCAR celebrity whose life is derailed after
he is outshone by a new driver played by Sacha
Baron Cohen. The rest of the supporting cast
includes Amy Adams, Michael Clarke Duncan,
and Jane Lynch, but this movie's blooper reel
puts the spotlight mostly on Ferrell and Reilly.
"Ninety-eight percent of us will
die at some point in our lives."
"The darkness is creeping towards
you, whether you know it or not."
The two comics bounce off each other
easily during outtakes of a dinner
party scene and make each other break
during chaotic scenes. It's no wonder they
reunited to make "Step Brothers" two years later.
"Rush Hour" was released in 1998, sparking a
multi-million dollar franchise led by action
star Jackie Chan and comedian Chris Tucker.
The two play an unlikely pair of cops tasked
with rescuing the kidnapped daughter of a
Chinese politician. This film is as thrilling
as it is hilarious, and audiences loved it so
much that they kept coming back for sequels.
Part of what made the "Rush Hour" films such
amazing theater-going experiences — besides
the appeal of the movies themselves — were
the end-credits blooper reels. Each of the
three installments in the "Rush Hour"
franchise includes a number of outtakes
that are shown off as the credits roll.
They’re excellent showcases of Chan's
charisma on set, as he never misses an
opportunity to be a true entertainer.
"Anything goes wrong, you bust in there
and act like you’re LAP— blah blah blahhh."
"He cannot speak English!"
Tucker is also a highlight of the "Rush Hour"
bloopers, even as he rarely breaks character.
Though Chan and Tucker may have seemed
like an odd pair before the release of
"Rush Hour," these end credits prove that
they're actually a match made in heaven.
A more recent film that showcases some quality
bloopers is the 2022 Paramount+ original film
"Honor Society." This movie stars Angourie Rice
as Honor Rose, a type-A student determined to
get her advisor's recommendation to Harvard
while competing with her classmate Michael,
played by Gaten Matarazzo of "Stranger
Things'' fame. Her initial plan to seduce
him as a distraction from his studies goes
awry when the two actually fall for each other,
imbuing this comedy with
tons of heart and tension.
However, "Honor Society" goes down a dark path
towards the end, as it's revealed that Michael
had been manipulating Honor the entire time
in an effort to secure the recommendation for
himself. Honor eventually one-ups Michael by
securing it instead for her friend Kennedy,
prioritizing her friendships over both
romance and her own academic success.
Nevertheless, the film closes out with
an end-credits blooper reel that leaves
audiences remembering the film's fun rather than
its darker aspects. Though it doesn't feature
as many outtakes or improvisational moments
from its cast, this kind of end-credits reel
showcases the chemistry between the film’s actors,
particularly Rice and Matarazzo as its leads.
Few end-credits blooper reels are as notable
as the one shown in the 1979 film "Being
There," directed by Hal Ashby of "Harold
and Maude" fame. This classic film stars
Peter Sellers as an oblivious gardener
who ends up becoming a political power
player after meeting a rich couple played
by Melvyn Douglas and Shirley Maclaine.
The film was one of Sellers' biggest hits and
garnered numerous award nominations and wins,
including a Golden Globe win for Sellers and a
best supporting actor Academy Award for Douglas.
Though it was more uncommon at the time,
"Being There" ends with a blooper reel of
a single scene as the credits roll.
We see Sellers struggle to keep a
straight face as he dryly quotes a man who
threatened him at knifepoint earlier on.
"What was the message, Mr. Gardener?"
"Now get this honky…"
Even though Sellers was seemingly a shoo-in for
best actor at the Oscars that year, the category
would eventually be won by Dustin Hoffman for his
performance in "Kramer vs. Kramer." According to
Douglas' granddaughter, Sellers felt the
end-credits blooper cost him the award,
revealing his brilliant performance in
the film as exactly that: a performance.
"This is 40," written and directed by Judd
Apatow, also features a single scene's
outtakes over its end credits. The 2012 comedy
mostly centers on Paul Rudd and Leslie Mann,
reprising their roles of Pete and Debbie
from Apatow's "Knocked Up" as they grapple
with parenthood, relationship issues, and
their careers. "This is 40" also features
an incredibly robust supporting cast,
including Megan Fox, John Lithgow, Jason
Segel [SEE-gul], Lena Dunham, and Chris O'Dowd,
but one particular star shines the brightest.
That would be Melissa McCarthy, who in 2012 was
rolling on the huge success of "Bridesmaids,"
which was released the previous year.
In "This is 40," she plays Catherine,
a fellow parent at Pete and Debbie's
children's school who files a complaint
with the principal for their daughters' behavior.
In the outtakes, McCarthy goes on a
rampaging improvisation about her violent
urges towards the two stoic parents, which causes
Rudd and Mann to break character several times.
"I would like to rear up and jackknife my legs and
kick you both in the f—ing jaw with my foot bone!"
It’s no wonder McCarthy became such a
Hollywood comedy staple in the years
that followed. Her appearance in "This is
40" was a precursor to her reign in studio
comedies throughout the 2010s, including
"Identity Thief," "The Heat," and "Spy."
"Horrible Bosses" features a powerful
sampling of comedic talent. The 2011
film centers on a group of three friends
— played by Jason Sudeikis, Jason Bateman,
and Charlie Day — whose frustrations with their
inept, sociopathic, and sadistic bosses result in
them planning to murder their superiors.
The movie is not only hilarious, but a
surprisingly thrilling comedic romp involving
murder, espionage, and life-or-death stakes.
Given the number of stars and laughs
involved, it's no wonder that this film
ends with a blooper reel over the credits.
The hilarious chemistry between Sudeikis,
Bateman, and Day is on full display as they
make each other break down laughing. Another
highlight includes Colin Farrell's hilarious
improvisations with a deadpan pharmacist,
a scene that didn't make the film's final cut.
Viewers found the blooper reel so entertaining
that one was included again in the film's sequel,
"Horrible Bosses 2," which also introduced
the talents of Chris Pine and Christoph Waltz.
Pixar earned its place in movie history with
a string of hits starting with "Toy Story" in
1995. That was quickly followed up with "A Bug's
Life" in 1998 and "Toy Story 2" in 1999. In 2001,
the studio would entrust Pete Docter to direct
his first of many Pixar films with "Monsters,
Inc.," which takes place in a world
where monsters harvest children’s
screams in order to fuel their city. The
film thrives due to its likable characters,
with its two leads, Sully and Mike, voiced by
John Goodman and Billy Crystal respectively.
Pixar’s animated blooper tradition began
with "A Bug’s Life," but "Monsters,
Inc." was the last of their productions to be
released with them in the credits. However,
unlike the other movies on this list,
Pixar outtakes aren't genuine mistakes.
"Go ahead… go throw up."
"What, what-ah what— what did I say? What, what?"
"Okay, cut!"
The outtakes of "Monsters, Inc." that play through
the credits are fully animated and voice-acted,
including a "Toy Story" cameo and several
scenes from the company play "Put That
Thing Back Where It Came From Or So Help
Me." This tradition, as brief as it was,
made Pixar’s characters even more
lovable than they already were.